abundance is our Birthright and
everywhere you look you see abundance
there's an abundance of leaves on the
tree there's an abundance of snow in the
ground there's an abundance of water in
the universe and you and I have the
ability to create an abundant now you
take nothing with you you'll never own
anything you arrive with nothing you're
going to leave the same way it's like
somebody said you come in with no hair
no teeth no money that's the way you
leave but while you're here you can
enjoy an abundant life now what would
abundance be in your life to one person
it may be different than to another but
understand this it all starts in our
mind most people are letting what they
have now control how they see themselves
they let their bank account control them
they let the friends they have control
them that's not where we want to go we
want to go inside everything starts from
the inside out if life isn't the way you
want it now make up your mind you're
going to start over you're going to sit
down you're going to write out how you
do want it hey it's Evan Carmichael and
I make these videos because in my first
business I was making 300 bucks a month
I quit on my business partner and the
thing that saved me was studying the
stories a super successful entrepreneurs
so I hope that this story today helps
give you the motivation you need because
I still needed to myself so today let's
live your best believe life and learn
the Practical steps to reprogram your
mind
enjoy
now we want abundance we want an
abundance of friends we want an
abundance of money we want an abundance
of all the good things in life that make
us more comfortable and have us enjoy
life to Greater degree and you know we
can have it
but we've got to understand we can have
it we've got to understand that we have
input infinite potential locked up
within us we've got a marvelous mind
we can think anything we want General
Victor Franco spent the War years in a
concentration camp
and he said regardless of the
intellectual or physical abuse he was
subjected to no one could cause him to
think something he didn't want to think
all the great leaders all down through
history have they have been completely
unanimous agreement we've become what we
think about well don't think lack of
limitation think abundance in whatever
you want see yourself with plenty with
abundance hold the image and then just
think how can I get this
by continually seeing yourself with it
the way to get it will start to come to
your mind you will attract whatever you
need
because you're getting on an abundant
frequency and it'll all start coming
into your life as you move towards it
it'll come towards you
abundance it's your Birthright
you've got to decide on it rule number
two is visualize with Marissa peer so
which gives you a little hint today a
little tip that is really going to help
you with your passion purpose your focus
your drive you know many many years ago
I was trying to get a book deal and I'd
put on a little talk about how to lose
weight because my book was all about
that and I hadn't sold hardly any
tickets so I canceled it and the same
day my agent called me went oh my gosh
I've got
um six different uh Publishers who want
to come to your talk I'm like well I
just can't this one put it back on quick
because they're all coming and it was
that weekend and I think she called me
on a Thursday night
so on the Friday I rang all my friends
everyone said come to this talk it's
completely free and and I got lots of
people to come because I knew that six
major publishing houses were coming to
this talk and she told me one of them
was definitely going to give me a deal
if not all of them so I only had Friday
and on Friday I could have spent ages
planning the tour but you know I didn't
I actually made a mood board I thought
that's a good thing so on Friday night I
had an old picture and I took it out of
the frame and I started to stick things
in it and I wrote Marissa Pier gets a
great book deal I I cut out the times uh
best-selling list and I stuck it in
there and wrote on it my book you can be
thin and I did lots and lots of pictures
that Marissa makes people thin I went
through magazines I cut stuff out I
wrote some checks out there I made this
mood ball really exciting and I just
looked at it and looked at it and looked
at it and it made me so excited about my
talk and the next day I went off and I
did the talk and lo and behold at the
end somebody came up to me and she said
oh my God I love that talk and we want
you to come in on Monday and we're going
to offer you a book deal straight away
and we'd really love you not to meet the
other five Publishers we want you so
that was very exciting and in fact I did
end up signing with them and it all was
wonderful but I know it was that mood
board that helped me because it took my
mind to where I wanted to be it made me
Focus only on success of course the mood
board doesn't say things like well I
might not make it the mood board has
success so let's imagine you want to be
a therapist
that's what your vision is or a
photographer maybe you want to be a chef
I want you to imagine you've got a mood
board and you fill it up with pictures
if you want to be a chef pictures of
great food reviews from restaurants and
of course you're going to cross out the
name of the chef and write your name in
and said in black marker pen so find
lots of reviews and put your name in and
then right all over the mood board too
let's say your name is Alexandra
Richardson you're going to put Alex
Richardson instead of that chef and
you're going to put lots of reviews and
let's say you've found
uh the top 10 best restaurants and
you're going to call your restaurant the
fox and so you cross that and you put
the fox Alex Richardson's restaurant the
fox and just keep looking at that and
you write all over your mood where all
the things that work for you people love
this restaurant the best restaurant in
wherever you live in the world the food
here is amazing and then you look at
lots of interviews with chefs and you
imagine your interview and you put it up
there you can even mock one up that's
what
printers have also mock up an interview
mock up everything and look at that mood
board mock up all the things that you're
going to cook they're going to give you
pleasure mock up the cookery book you're
going to write mock up so much stuff you
know a couple of years ago I was asked
to work with probably the angriest kid
I've ever worked with in my life and
when we started to work he said you know
no one loves me I have no love in my
life and I realized that his anger was
actually incredible pain but I talked to
him
and I asked him what he was good at he
said nothing so asked him what he loved
he said cooking so we talked about that
a bit and he's ended up being a
phenomenally successful Chef he's got a
great girlfriend
he went to work for other chefs he's now
got his own restaurant his life has
changed dramatically because I found one
thing that he loved and focused on his
purpose
and the reason he was here and he loved
cooking so much that I knew straight
away that that's what he was meant to do
and now he's doing it his life has
changed 360 Degrees mood boards have
been proven over and over again to
stimulate your brain to excite your
imagination to keep your focus on where
you want to go
when you focus on where you want to go
you actually go towards it the more you
focus on where you want to be the more
your mind like a heat-seeking missile
takes you to where you want to be
so if you want to be an Olympic Athlete
you'd have to take a lot of action you
have to practice a lot and train a lot
if you don't want to do something
physical train your mind practice with
your mind use mood boards I've done
quite a few radio interviews about why
mood boards are so successful why people
who have everything tend to have mood
boards now the mood board I made years
ago I put it above my bed which is an
odd thing to do actually because I face
away from it so I don't look at it every
day anymore but a little while ago I
looked at it and I realized that every
single thing I put on that mood board
had come true in fact when I finished
with all the um
things I was going to do as a writer I
put up some pictures one was hot air
ballooning and one was something else
and I realized that every single thing
I'd put up I think one was riding a
camel I'd actually done all of those so
I thought well I better make a new mood
board now with new things I want I wrote
down some of the countries I wanted to
go to
so if you put it above your bed do make
sure that you look at it better to put
it really on your fridge or in your
kitchen or in your office you can also
take a big photograph of it and make
that your screensaver and the wallpaper
on your phone because then of course you
will look at it every day over and over
again but even though I made that mood
board and put it in a place where I
didn't look at it and actually looked
away from it guess what it still worked
so imagine how it will work if it's
right in your line of vision if it's on
your computer screen and I work with
many many women who are having huge
problems conceiving and I get them to
make a baby board same thing but it's a
picture of a positive pregnancy test
colored into yes it's lots of pictures
of babies
and I have them also put on Instagram
and on their computer screen so they see
it every day and the success rates with
using that baby board are
phenomenal make your mood board use it
look at it it will really help you take
action because it will excite your
imagination it will motivate you and it
will inspire your potential As you move
towards your potential it expands so
don't Focus too much on where you are
now because guess what your potential
expands As you move towards it you know
what that means it means you can never
know what your potential is because as
you move towards it it expands
so you may think I just want to get a
job on a kitchen I'd love to work in a
kitchen cooking and as you start that if
you think actually I'd like to
be the senior Chef in this kitchen and
that will move to I want my own
restaurant I want my own cookery book I
want my own cookery program there's
nothing wrong with any of that
one of my clients just wanted to be a
vet that's all she wanted to be but she
couldn't be a vet because she was asked
to leave that veterinary school twice
because she dropped out of school before
she was fully educated and they said no
sorry
she couldn't afford to go back a third
time anyway and she was so depressed
about that and said look it isn't black
or white why do you want to be a veteran
I love animals I just want to work with
animals and so I spoke to her
and asked her to consider being working
in a charity for animals and and being
an animal trainer one of my friends a
guy called Jerry Cott who used to be in
the Boomtown Rats as a fantastic animal
trainer he trains animals for all the
different adverts you'll see on
television and for movies too and so I
got him to speak to her and lo and
behold she started off working in a dog
and cat rescue shelter and then she
trained to be an animal behavioral
expert and then she got her own show so
her potential went from working in this
animal rescue center being paid to work
in an animal rescue center
training to be an animal behavioral
expert writing a book and getting my own
television show that was extraordinary
all because that was what her heart
wanted to do that's all she ever wanted
to do and as she's doing and you know
what she's happier and worth more
financially she's ever been a vet if
she'd been a vet she'd be happy doing
what she's done has made her ecstatic
and financially more successful happier
in every way possible so keep thinking
about your goals use that mood one
remember your potential expands
As you move towards it where you are now
it doesn't matter you have no idea what
your potential is because it's going to
move as you move towards it and when
your mind moves to New Dimensions guess
what it never ever ever goes back only
goes forward rule number three is feel
the energy with Mel Robbins you're gonna
feel in your body what it feels like to
do the work so let's go back to the
research project at UCLA not only do I
want you to close your eyes and picture
yourself going back to the dorm room
notice I'm closing my eyes it's because
manifesting is a habit for me and when I
manifest I get in it man I close my eyes
I go into my mind I am literally in my
imagination there and I not only can see
myself doing the work I can feel it you
can feel what it's like to walk into
that dorm you can feel what it's like to
sit down you can feel the heavy backpack
hit the table you can feel yourself
crack open that book you can feel
yourself sitting at that desk in the
desk light and you can also even feel
what it's like can't you as the Sun
starts to set and it gets darker outside
and the light on your desk starts to get
brighter and take things over you can
just put yourself right there and the
feeling is super important because again
manifesting is Mind Body Spirit we got
to get your nervous system involved
we've got to make you feel like you're
at the scene one of the reasons why
feeling it is so important is because it
magnifies the imagery in your mind
and when your mind rehearses something
here's what's cool about your brain your
brain doesn't know the difference
between you studying for that test
or you doing the work to
start that business or get healthy or
put yourself back out there or heal your
trauma or save the money to get that
house that you want or whatever it is
that you're visualizing your brain
doesn't know the difference between you
visualizing those things
and you actually doing them in your mind
it's the same so it's almost like a
training run for a marathon you are
building a muscle that helps you win
when you take the actions it's so cool
and so you not only want to feel what
it's like to study for that test put
yourself at the scene you also want to
feel a sense of Pride that you're doing
the work and the pride piece is really
important because the pride piece acts
almost like a booster it amplifies the
memory imprint when you like bring this
WOW there I am I'm doing the work I'm
proud of myself I'm staying in I'm
putting in the extra work somebody said
no and I kept on going I didn't stop
when the first Venture Capital firm said
they wouldn't invest there I am
investing again when you feel this sense
of pride in yourself it supersizes the
imprint and the rehearsing and so it's a
super important part of the feeling not
only feel the steps feel the pride that
you're doing it this is so important
that I want to give you yet another
example let's say that your bucket list
something on your bucket list is to run
a marathon for me it was on my bucket
list when I was a young mom to run the
New York City marathon now what's
interesting is I applied I got a number
and when I won this number out of a
lottery system with the New York City
marathon I was a brand new mom I was
totally out of shape I was not at all in
any kind of of a place to run the New
York City marathon now here's the thing
I used visualization to help me
lower my fear and my excuses because
when I got the number I did not have a
lot of time if I had been a person who
was not visualizing I probably would
have said uh I don't have enough time to
train I'm not ready I can't do this all
the excuses would have come in but
instead I used visualization now how do
you use visualization for say a marathon
you do not want to visualize crossing
the finish line that is how you
visualize incorrectly
luckily I knew how to visualize at this
moment in my life you need to visualize
yourself going from zero
to preparing to run that race so what
does that mean that means you need to
visualize oh there I am it's five
o'clock in the morning oh I don't feel
like getting up but I'm getting up and
I'm putting on my sneakers and it's dark
out and I don't feel like going for a
run but there I am going out the door
alone in the cold wow I am going for I'm
I'm pretty proud of myself because I'm
training oh here's another thing you
could visualize I'm on a training run
it's Mile seven and it starts to rain
and I keep going
wow I'm wet and I'm still running I'm
proud of myself because I'm out there
training it's mile 11 and my earbuds
just lost battery
I don't have any more music
I got five more miles to go I'm out here
for almost another hour and I continue
going and I continue going and I see
myself completing that 16 mile training
run and I allow myself to not only feel
what it feels like to push through that
moment when those earbuds run out of
battery
but I also feel proud of myself for
pushing through that's how you prepare
yourself
for the thing that you need to do
because it removes the obstacles that
would stop you from pushing through at
Mile 11 when your earbuds run out
because you've already rehearsed the
moment in your mind also to make sure
you're actually taking action after
watching this video I designed a special
free worksheet just for this video the
worksheet will highlight all the Lessons
Learned in this video as well as pull
out our three favorite learnings and
quotes that will inspire you to actually
do something the worksheet will also
give you space to write down what your
key takeaways are and your specific plan
of action to make sure you're getting
results if you want the worksheet
designed specifically for this video
absolutely for free there's a link in
the description below go click on it and
start building the momentum in your life
and your business I'll see you there
rule number four is choose small things
with Rhonda Byrne okay so this question
is from Louisa
um she asked
I used to attract absolutely everything
and because of different situations I
lost my power to attract things and lost
belief in myself what can I do to fix it
I was an example of attracting all
things
now here's the amazing thing you never
lose your power ever it's impossible you
can't lose it but you can create or
attract the experience of not having
power
that's the re that's how powerful you
are you are so powerful that you can
create not being powerful at all and so
you are powerful you're attracting every
single second of your life not just the
things that you want attractings and
things that you don't want to so
um probably the best thing to do if you
remember when you started you probably
started with something small if you're
feeling you're not attracting things
just go back and choose something small
because you don't have a lot of
resistance around something small like
if I say to you attract a cup of coffee
today
in your body you will feel oh yeah I can
do that I can do that whereas if I say
to you attract ten thousand dollars
today you'll be like you'll have
resistance so choose small things and
that will rebuild your confidence but
let me tell you you are all the power
there is and so whatever you say goes
even if you're saying I'm not powerful
and I've lost it rule number five is
Manifest from a clear place with Gabby
Bernstein I know many of you are very
interested in the Law of Attraction and
very interested in manifesting I know
that you do understand that you attract
towards you your likeness whatever it is
that you think and you feel is going to
be reflected back to you and that we
start to practice principles in our life
to really call in what we desire and as
wonderful as that is and as magnificent
it is as it is to understand the power
that our energy holds it's important to
really make sure that we're manifesting
from a Clean and Clear Place
and so I suggest whenever I engage in
this dialogue with anybody that you
begin first and foremost to be clear
about what it is that you want so having
a very clear focus and then let it go we
have these visions of exactly what we
want and then when we focus on what it
is exactly we block other opportunities
so for instance I talk a lot about my
coach raw goddess in my first book
admiring to your life and raw was so
hyper focused on having this man look a
certain way sound a certain way and be
tall and black and successful and there
was this amazing man that came into her
life and he had everything that was on
her list except he was short and white
and so had she not let go of her Clear
Vision she would never have met her
husband or allowed him to become her
beloved so I think it's very valuable
that we pay close attention to the
clarity with which what we want comes
through but then we also can let it go
that we can just allow it to be and so
our job is to be clear and released at
the same time the biggest and most
important element of manifesting is to
cultivate the feeling of what it is that
you want to experience and so when we're
feeling a sense of lack or we're feeling
a sense of deprivation or feeling lonely
or creating more of that experience in
our life it's the feeling more than the
thought that creates the form
so start to really cultivate a greater
understanding of how you want to feel
and then do whatever it takes that you
can to support that feeling so if you
want to feel loved and you want to find
romance then make sure that you are
loving yourself very deeply if you want
to feel abundant and you want to create
more money in your life then make sure
that you are respecting your money and
that you are paying your bills and that
you are allowing yourself to indulge
when you can and so being very conscious
of entertaining that feeling and
cultivating that feeling and as you
start to dwell in that feeling that
feeling becomes your reality
and so these three steps really start to
pay attention about being clear but
released at the same time cultivate the
feeling and then take actions to really
support the feeling and rule number six
the last one before some very special
bonus Clips is do things that move the
needle with Dean graziosi the law of
attraction is it really the secret to
success and does it really work listen I
know for a fact that in my 20s when I
was fixing cars during the day I was
painting cars sucking fumes had
headaches every night I literally drove
a tow truck at night while
simultaneously I was getting into real
estate and the only way I could do is is
get no money down deals the worst deals
in town so I get done working on cars at
five or six eat and then go work on
houses until I know sometimes two
o'clock in the morning tired get up do
it again now during those times I was
envisioning a bigger future I was hoping
to be a millionaire someday I was hoping
to retire my mom who works so hard to
make you know she work like three jobs
to make ninety dollars a week and I
envisioned me having money I envisioned
the big house but there was a part I was
missing back then hey if you don't
already know who I am I'm Dean graciosi
I'm a multiple New York Times
best-selling author my new book
millionaire success habits on fire right
now you probably see it everywhere I've
been able to start and scale 13
different companies my Brands and my
companies have done hundreds of millions
of dollars in sales in like 30 years of
being an entrepreneur and I love this
topic The Law of Attraction because
there's so many different opinions but
in my experience going from someone who
didn't go to college or coming from
someone who didn't go to college and
used to work Blue Collar hard hands
dirty which there's nothing wrong with
it and evolving to big business doing
hundreds of millions of dollars touching
the lives of people all around the world
multiple New York Times best-selling
books all those great things I really
dialed in what I believe and I think is
the truth about the law of attraction
you see I remember when the secret went
viral was at 8 10 maybe even 12 years
ago I don't even remember but the secret
went viral it's still a strong selling
book and to manifest to create vision
boards to Envision and picture and
meditate on your bigger future is an
absolute must like teach it in my book
it's a habit you must have you must
create a compelling future for yourself
if you focus on what you don't want
anymore if you focus on what your
parents have if you focus on what your
friends family even parents or loved
ones tell you you should do or listen to
the naysayers or listen to the negative
news I'm sorry to say that's the results
you'll get what you focus on is what you
get but what happened with the secret it
stopped there it's not just about the
vision board it's not just about having
a compelling future that pulls you
towards a better bigger version of you
towards your next level towards living
your your full potential that's all
wonderful but the part that's missing is
action now you're saying oh Dean you're
brilliant no I'm saying that because a
lot of people do miss it we create a
vision board we want to manifest we
focus on our bigger future but then we
go back to the same old habits we had
prior the same thinking that got you
here is not the same thinking that will
get you to where you want to go one of
my mentors said the thinking the the
habits that got you out of Egypt are not
the same habits that are going to take
you to the promised land
so the Law of Attraction it's a Hot
Topic books everybody's talking about it
and it continues to go but I want to
tell you the definition of success is
taking that principle taking the Law of
Attraction but then how do you change
your habits how do you change your
routines and how do you stop doing the
things that don't move the needle in
your life that bring you down that cause
negativity that Rob your confidence or
you just do out of a hypnotic rhythm
because everybody else used to or you
hang around the negative people or you
surf online for hours and you wonder why
your business isn't working you have to
quit those things open up space and
start doing more of the things that move
the needle my buddy Tony Robbins I love
when he when he's on stage he says
listen you can sit in your garden you
could close your eyes and meditate and
say weeds don't grow weeds don't grow
weeds don't grow it goes but when you
open your eyes unless you pull the weeds
they will grow same thing here
manifested vision board have a
compelling future but get out there and
take action and a lot of times it's as
simple as throwing away the things that
don't move the needle in your life stop
doing this that doesn't serve you
doesn't serve God doesn't serve making
more money and then even one step higher
stop doing the things other people
taught you are the definition of success
stop spending months wondering what your
website should look like or what color
your logo should be and start spending
time on marketing and sales and
understanding your avatar stop listening
to the naysayers in your life and dig in
following those who have already forged
the path in front of you listen there
are over 1700 new millionaires a day
being created in America think of that
number I get so many people say to me oh
the old days Dean it was easier for you
to become a millionaire back in the day
no this is the time social media the
internet the world becoming smaller has
literally opened up the opportunity for
so many people to have the chance to be
wealthy to to live to their full
potential to grab self-education learn
on your own learn from those who are
already doing it and go faster and
quicker but it takes more than
manifestation you have to take action
and you have to change your habit
the science that says there are two
minds that are operating at the same
time one is called the conscious mind or
one is called the subconscious mind I
say What's the difference
the conscious mind is where you are as a
spirit an entity a unique identity you
are in that conscious mind and
perceiving the world I say what about
the subconscious mind it's not a
creative mind the subconscious mind is
habits things that you've learned and
you experienced in your life and they
become habits so uh the subconscious
mind is not thinking creating a
subconscious mind push the button play
the behavior
so here's the point
when we are in our conscious mind we are
connecting our spirituality to the
biology and the physical planet that
we're in and that is a creative mind
that's the one you wake up in the
morning and say oh I wish I had this and
I desire that and these are things I
want and then you go out and start the
day and then guess what
95 of the day you are not operating from
the conscious mind science has recognize
95 of the day because we are thinking 95
of the day our behavior is now
controlled by the subconscious mind
I go okay so what's the difference in
the final conclusion of this is the
conscious mind with your creativity has
your wishes and your desires
the subconscious mind was programmed by
other people your mother your father
your siblings and your community so what
is the difference you wake up with a
wish and a desire of what you want
and then the rest of the day you play
the programs that you got from other
people that don't answer your wishes and
don't support your desires and all you
see is the consequence of it and go oh
my God why is it not working the answer
is because you don't see because
remember the name is subconscious below
conscious so when that behavior is
playing
psychologists will tell us 70 percent or
more of the programs in the subconscious
are disempowering
self-sabotaging and limiting behaviors
so the simple reality is this we have
great wishes and desires and yet our
life is not controlled by that our life
is controlled by the programming and
that programming is the disempowering
program so all you see is the
consequence of the invisible
subconscious which will sabotage all the
desires and wishes you have and then to
conclude that
what if you just didn't default to the
subconscious what if you just stayed in
the conscious mind that's called being
Mindful and why is it relevant because
when you stay conscious keep your mind
present you are the creator of your life
and when people are in mindfulness they
manifest their wishes their desires and
their happiness so for all of us it's
sort of a wake-up call you think you're
running your life with your wishes and
desires it's an illusion you're really
running your life with your programs
acquired from other people in our mind
we start to realize that we're concerned
we're afraid we don't have enough I'm
not safe I'm not secure and I say oh
these thoughts I was talking about the
thoughts in your mind go in and control
your biology your genetics your
physiology and your health and I go yes
this is really true I say well how can I
tell you what your thoughts are in a
sense that can I read your thoughts and
I say yes you know I could put wires on
your head and it's called
electroencephalograph and I could read
your brain activity and I go oh great I
can see this brain activity
I want to tell you something that's
profoundly important
we were programmed to believe that our
thoughts are contained in our head that
if I have a thought it's just for me not
for anybody else it's inside and it's
working through me
and now I want to tell you about a new
technology it's not
electroencephalograph it's called
Magneto
encephalograph I say what's unique about
that I say read your brain I say yeah
but so does EEG I say yeah but EEG put
the wires on the head and you get the
electrical activity conducted through
the skin from the brain and that's what
I'm reading and I said what's different
about Meg
the probe is out here
and I said what does that mean
your thoughts are not contained in your
head your thoughts are broadcast to the
field just like a radio broadcast I said
well what if I as an individual have a
thought that says let's have peace in
the world
and I broadcast out there in the street
and I say let's have peace and I look
around it's like where's the piece I
don't see the peace and here's what the
relevance is
each of us is broadcasting
if you get enough people
to have the same thought
that broadcast is Amplified each of us
has a small power
but if you put a thousand people the
same thought ten thousand a hundred
thousand people with the same thought
you are broadcasting a most powerful
thought not just in your body but out in
the field I say your Energy's in the
field the thought is in the field and
you go well what does that mean and then
I'll give you this most wonderful quote
I used it the other day in a lecture
from Albert Einstein
and the quote is so important here's the
quote
the field so a definite definition the
field is the invisible energy right now
you're in a field there's cell phone
broadcast television television radio
broadcast all kinds of information
coming across but guess what each one of
you is a broadcast in that field the
quote the field
is the sole governing agency of the
particle
particle is the material Realm
so what was Einstein saying it's the
energy in the field that shapes the
physical experience of our lives and if
enough of us collectively have an energy
that's coherent and strong and we
broadcast the belief we change the world
I just want you to recognize as much as
I wanted peace in the world if not
enough people are out there saying let's
have peace in the world there is no
peace
if I want to say let's have a war how
can you have a war you have to have
enough people convinced that the war is
going to benefit them so that their
broadcasts say yes let's have a war
because I and my colleagues we're all
going to have a better result from that
and the reality is this
the only things that change on this
planet collectively are when we
collectively share thoughts
and yoga when you're in your postures
when you're in your process your mind is
sharing a thought not just in your head
but all around you so the whole idea
about this is we have to recognize we
are collectively creating reality with
our thoughts
and if we want to change reality it can
change instantly
the moment we become coherent the moment
we collectively are on the same platform
of thinking you get enough people to say
peace there will be peace instantly in
this world
but we've been programmed by other
people to give them the power to tell us
what we need
and as side Vegeta has been telling us
so importantly what we need is not what
they tell us what we need is what we
know
and I really hope that you understand
this because when you have your thoughts
recognized it's not contained in your
head your thoughts out in the field and
that thought the field is the soul
governing agency of matter
and therefore what this world is looking
for at this moment is an evolution
it's not an evolution of our biology our
biology has already evolved
it's an evolution of our consciousness
when we collectively as a population say
enough is enough it will end see the
only criteria you have to have when you
set a goal is do you want it
do you want it doesn't matter how you're
going to do it it doesn't matter where
the money's coming from I want shared a
cute story with the maharashi when he
was taking Transcendental Meditation or
decided he was going to take him to the
world one of his Close Associates said
where's the money going to come from he
said wherever it is right now I always
thought it was such a beautiful answer
because the truth everything you need
everything you want is already here
nothing is created or destroyed I didn't
dream this up it's the way it is all
science all theology tell us that the
way to get the moon was already here
always here when President John Kennedy
asked Dr Warner Von Braun who's
considered the the father in space
travel what it would take to build a
rocket that would carry him into the
moon and bring him back safely to Earth
Von Braun answered I mean five words the
will to do it
the will to do it will is a mental
faculty that gives us the ability to
concentrate you got to concentrate on
what you want that's all you can
concentrate on and that will keep you on
the frequency that you have to be on to
attract everything that you need to get
there
this is so important
to say I believe decision where it all
starts
it's where it all started for Napoleon
Hill
it all started when Carnegie asked him
are you prepared to dedicate the rest of
your life to an idea
for which you'll probably receive no
material compensation for at least 20
years how would you answer that
you see he didn't know how to do that he
didn't even believe he could
you know what I found when you set a
goal you don't have to believe it
if you keep repeating it you'll come to
believe it if you tell yourself a lie
often enough you'll believe it
way back in 1900 William James from
Harvard he said believe that your belief
will create the fact
so true so true and so misunderstood
so what do you want
compare your dream
to Napoleon Hill's idea
just compare it for a moment
your idea is probably small by
comparison
but if you don't know how to do it if
you don't know where the money's coming
from if you don't know where the help is
going to come from
you'll probably seem large
when I took my pen and I sat down and I
wrote I would build a company that
operated all over the world
I had no idea how I was going to do it I
certainly didn't have the finances to it
I didn't have the help I didn't even
have an assistant I was just me in my
Den riding on a pad
do you know something
today I own a company
along with Sandy Gallagher who is my
business partner and we operate all over
the world
these aren't accidents
I'm just an ordinary guy
that's doing what the public would
consider something extraordinary but
it's not extraordinary to me and it's
not going to be to you when you start to
understand these principles and
incorporate them into your life I
mentioned we want to build schools in
Africa for kids that have never seen a
school
and so we're building them there's many
things we want to do we do them all I
never wonder if I can do something
I just ask myself do I want to
I think God meant us to live
I believe we're doing God's work
somebody said what God's word god well
if God's a Creator then God's work would
be creation we've been given the mental
faculties to create
we've been created in God's image
somewhere along the line way back when
somebody got that mixed up
[Music]
they thought when they said you're
creating God's image that God was
created in their image so they're
looking for a man on a cloud there is no
man on a cloud but I'm going to tell you
something
you got some phenomenal stuff locked up
inside of you you bring it to the
surface you can live anything you want
great way to live the voice within us
that believes that we are not allowed to
be happy
our card today is speaking to that
I believe I'm worthy of feeling good I
believe I am worthy of feeling good this
is often something that is a belief
system that sounds really nice but it's
actually far from our reality because
many of us have been brought up with the
belief system that we have to suffer to
succeed that we have to feel pain to
have purpose that we have to have
struggles in order to feel a sense of
Serenity in our life that is all quite
backwards it's when we feel good that we
actually attract more of what we want
into our life but we have to undo the
belief system that says who am I to feel
good who am I to feel great who am I to
be happy that belief system is an
ingrained belief system that can be
cultural that can be something that we
learned from our upbringing it can be
something that we have picked up from
this difficult experience that we're
going through right now with covid when
we witness people suffering we think
well how dare I be happy I would say to
you how dare you not be happy it's your
happiness it's the collective happiness
it's the group Collective happiness that
raises the energetic frequency of the
world if we those of us who have moments
of happiness and Grace and joy and
success and we don't celebrate them we
are doing the world a disservice we are
shutting down the light we are bringing
down the vibration so we have to when we
feel good we have to reach for more when
we feel good we have to recognize that
that good feeling emotion has momentum
it has power it elevates our children it
elevates our family members it elevates
our friends it elevates strangers on the
street it is your Divine Duty here on
Earth to bring forth that greatness that
goodness that light so when you hear
that voice that says to you you are not
worthy of feeling good I want you to
hear my voice come through and say to
you who are you not to feel good
this is your Divine Purpose it is your
mission and it is the way that you heal
and serve you got me
we are more comfortable being
uncomfortable than we are being happy
so when things are good and when we
start to get a sense of feeling good
our ego the voice of fear within us
starts to say hell no too good to be
true and it will find these weird little
Corners to pick up problems
we have a fault-finding mindset rather
than a solution happiness oriented
mindset so when that happens the next
time you notice that you're feeling good
and all is well and all of a sudden
you're like but I wasn't nice enough to
that person or my co-workers aren't in a
good place or I didn't do that right I
want you to speak back to that voice I
want you to say thank you for sharing
but I choose happiness instead
thank you for sharing but I don't
believe that voice anymore thank you for
sharing but I'm choosing this moment
give yourself permission in the moment
to speak back to the fault-finding voice
and start to claim the greatness of who
you are that is a pattern because you've
lived your life in a habitual pattern of
seeking problems and finding fault now
we have to redirect and create a new
habit and pattern of grounding you in
the truth of who you are which is
happiness joy peace and Grace sharing
that happiness joy and peace with so
much grace
that's what you're here for several
years ago I went to see a friend of mine
and he is considered by all means one of
the leading experts in the world on EEG
and brainwave frequencies and really
understanding how our brain waves affect
how we feel and what we think about and
I went to this bio-cybernaut institute
to be able to recognize one thing number
one was that my thoughts happened
randomly as a result of all of the years
of learning experiencing listening to my
parents my teachers my brother my sister
and myself and as a result of that I
developed these neural patterns or brain
patterns that created these automatic
thoughts some of them are positive some
of them were negative however what I
learned at The biocybernaut Institute
was that I could control my thoughts now
listen to me for just a moment if you
think about this are you your brain
well the answer is no your brain is an
organ however your brain has billions of
cells and those cells connect and talk
to each other every time you have a
positive thought you reinforce that
thought pattern every time you have a
negative thought you reinforce that
thought pattern even faster now the
reason that your brain does this is
because it wants to protect you from any
real or imagined danger and so a
negative thought is something that
happens in the brain that when it
happens it reinforces itself way faster
than the positive thought so one of the
things that you can do
is this number one is give your brain a
command since you're not your brain you
can do this and science has proven this
you can give your brain a command to let
you become aware of when you're having a
negative thought or even a negative
emotion so the first spot or the first
part that you need to take control over
is the awareness part of what's
happening within you
then the next part is to recognize and
realize that you don't have to play into
a negative thought you don't have to let
it control you you can actually observe
your negative thought you can observe
even a negative emotion or an unpleasant
emotion and you can surrender to it and
what does that mean surrender doesn't
mean give up surrender just means allow
it to happen without getting emotionally
attached to it now if you become aware
of an emotional or mental thought that
you have that's negative and you
surrender to it and just allow it to
Flow by you can use the word next in
order to give your brain a command to
move on to the next thought or to move
on to the next emotion and so as you're
aware of it as you surrender to it and
use the word next what I want you to do
next is refocus your brain on what you
want the thought to be and the emotion
to be so you can choose a polar opposite
thought
that will really Empower you
to have the right emotion and more
importantly will Empower you to take
action around the new thought and
emotion so again the three steps are
become aware of your thoughts and your
emotions surrender to them by allowing
them to happen let them go by release
them by saying the word next and then
refocus your thoughts on what you want
to achieve what you want to take action
on and that way you'll start to be in
control of your thoughts your emotions
which will then drive the behaviors that
you want in order to achieve the goals
that are most important to you your
personality literally ad is made up of
how you think how you act and how you
feel
and how you think how you act and how
you feel is your personality and your
personality is intimately connected to
your personal reality your life so then
if you want to change your life your
personal reality you got to change your
personality and here we go again you got
to start becoming conscious of your
unconscious thoughts you got to start
noticing how you act how you speak you
got to pay attention to how you're
feeling some people would live in guilt
their whole entire life and don't even
know it's guilt because at least it
feels like them so then when you start
doing that you begin to objectify your
subjective self so so then
when you begin to make small changes
back the thought a new thought should
lead to a new Choice a new Choice should
lead to a new Behavior a new Behavior
should create a new experience and a new
experience should create a new emotion
yes and that new emotion is teaching
your body chemically to understand what
your mind is intellectually understood
now your body is embodying the truth
right so then the new emotion should
Inspire new thoughts and that's called
Evolution so how do we get stuck
it's really simple
the stronger the emotion you feel from
some event in your life be it a betrayal
or a trauma or whatever yes the more
altered you feel inside of you the more
you pay attention to the cause outside
of you so the brain takes a snapshot it
freezes an image and embosses that
pattern neurologically in the brain
that's called a memory so we create
long-term memories from strong emotional
events okay so is that true that I just
want to understand the maybe the larger
the event in terms of its emotion to you
the stronger of a hold it has over you
yeah well the more it's embossed in your
biology so some certain people have a
strong experience in their life and it
catches all of the brain's attention so
now they think neurologically within the
circuits of the past experience and they
feel chemically within the boundaries of
those emotions and so how you think and
how you feel creates a state of being
now here's the problem that if you don't
know how to mediate or control your
emotional reaction to that event and you
keep that refractory period of chemicals
going on with extended periods of time
so that the event produces a chemical
change and the body needs to return back
to homeostasis or balance but if it
can't then the elongation of that
emotional reaction
for weeks say for days or weeks is
called a mood so you say Ed what's wrong
with you I'm in a mood why are you in a
mood well this thing happened to me five
days ago and I'm having one long
emotional reaction so then what you do
is you keep telling the story about it
keep firing and wiring the same circuits
and you keep conditioning the body into
the past so then you wake up in the
morning you look for the emotion so then
now all of a sudden you keep it
lingering for for for weeks or months
that's called the temperament well why
is he so angry I don't know let's ask
him why are you so angry well this thing
happened to me eight months ago I'm
having one long emotional reaction I'm
memorizing my emotions you keep it going
on for years on end that's called a
personality trait so then a person then
is memorizing themselves by living in
the past and so then you say to them
well tell me the story now the latest
research on memory says that 50 percent
of what we talk about in our past isn't
even the truth so we make stuff up about
the past in other words people are
reliving a life that they didn't even
have just to reaffirm that they can't
change right wow so then what's the
significance of this where you place
your attention is where you place your
energy period yes so then the stronger
the emotion that you have the some
problem or condition or person in your
life the more you're paying attention to
them so they captured your attention so
you're giving your power hour away wow
to that person right because they're
capturing your attention so then there's
an energetic connection to every person
everything everything in your past
present reality has your energy
connected to it so now this is the
significance when a person really
decides to be defined by a vision of the
future instead of the memory of the past
the hardest part about it is all of a
sudden becoming conscious and not making
the same unconscious choice so then
if you lower the volume to your
frustration to your hatred to your anger
if you truly knew how to do that if you
lower the volume to that emotion you
would take your attention off that
person which means you would begin to
break those energetic bonds and now
you're taking your power back yes you're
calling energy back to you and we've
measured this and all of a sudden it
builds this bigger electronic magnetic
field around the person's body that's
energy to heal that's energy to create a
new future with right and then if you
didn't want to lower the volume to the
emotion then just take your attention
off the person and every time you take
your attention off the person if you
became conscious of that you wouldn't
feel the emotion now the body though has
been addicted to that emotion because
you're using that person to reaffirm
your addiction to hatred or frustration
and if that person died you'd find
another one so then here you go now so
now you're in a position now where you
begin to lower the volume to that
emotion and the body's going wait a
second you've been you've been doing
this for the last 20 years and all of a
sudden you're just going to stop hating
and the body says well I've been
conditioned this way and conditioning is
based on the past so when the body feels
the the lack of that emotion just like a
drug addict it says hey you're off
schedule here so now the body starts
influencing the mind to think about
experiences that are embossed in the
brain that are based on that emotion so
the emotion now is causing you to think
in the past if we teach a person then
how to trade that frustration or that
hatred for an elevated emotion and
they'll say yeah but you know it was my
ex's fault or I got betrayed by my
partner in business yeah yeah we know
that okay so let's take your partner in
business or take your ex let's duct tape
them put them in a cannon and shoot them
to the moon now what are you gonna do
sooner or later you got to reckon with
yourself and change right so then teach
a person then how to trade that emotion
for an elevated emotion now trade the
emotion for an elevated emotion right so
you're going to give that up and you're
going to practice feeling gratitude for
as an example yes the person says well I
can't feel gratitude and I say
absolutely you can because you don't
practice feeling it you practice
spending most of your time feeling
hatred and frustration so now it's going
to take a little time to cause that
heart of you to bloom or you're part of
yours to bloom once they're able to feel
even the smallest measure of gratitude
where they start feeling appreciation
thankfulness
gratitude it's emotional signature when
you when you get something when you're
receiving something
when something has happened to you
uh or when something is happening to you
you say thank you because you're
receiving something so the emotional
signature
of gratitude means the event has already
happened where it's happening to you so
the moment you open your heart and you
feel gratitude well that emotion then is
telling the body that the experience has
already occurred and the thought then
can make it into the body because it's
consistent with the thought so now
you're beginning to program the
autonomic nervous system into a very
specific Destiny you got to maintain
that modified State of Mind and Body
your entire day independent of the
conditions in your outer environment
independent of your body's Cravings of
those emotions and habituations and
independent from time and if you can get
ready because something weird or unusual
some synchronicity some coincidence some
opportunity is going to land in your lap
and you didn't have to go and get it yes
it came to you now you're the vortex of
creation so if you say to me well I was
feeling gratitude but then there was
traffic or my co-worker sent me a nasty
email then I would say oh my God God you
mean you're allowing your environment
your outer environment to control how
you feel and think you're back to the
unconscious program that you're the
victim to your life you got it but when
you start producing those outcomes in
your life you're going to pay attention
to what you did inside of you and you're
going to believe more that you're the
creator of your life and less of a
victim of your life you have no idea
what you're capable of you have no idea
you have no idea the person you could be
the things you could accomplish the
things you can do the people you can
serve you have no idea that's why I
don't like 10-year goals 10-year goals
think about who you used to be 10 years
ago you know could that person
accurately with any with any degree of
certainty predict where you could be
right now now like if you're growing and
you're learning you're improving and
you're expanding
you're invested in yourself there's no
way that you know where you're going to
be in one year let alone five years or
ten years you have no idea what you're
capable of and so it comes down to
questioning everything
the question what you can and can't do
you know we're told the story growing up
of what you should do and we're told
everything right you're told when to
show up and where to go and what to wear
and what to eat and what at what age you
should get married and what kind of crew
you should go into right we're told we
should do all these things you're told
you're like who you know nobody ever
thought to ask us what we want for our
lives and you may not even know and
that's okay like you may know where you
want to go next but you may not
ultimately know the Final Destination
it's awesome
you know I think if you know the Final
Destination you're thinking small apart
from having a mission you know the
mission the purpose why do you do what
you do well I want to solve the world's
biggest problem people don't believe in
themselves enough that's what I'm
chasing down every day
do I know where I'm going to be in in a
year nope am I still making videos
probably but who knows like question
everything I want to I want people to
believe in themselves more what's the
best way to do that right now it's
through YouTube
but I think a lot of times people have
too certain of a plan and then they end
up
plain small because there's nothing
wrong with having goals and planes but
sometimes you need to jump off that if
you have a 10-year goal quite often you
need to jump off that goal two years in
because something better has come along
that actually better serves who you are
right now because the goal you set was
for who you used to be
you know have you felt that and so I'm
here at genius Network and this group of
super successful entrepreneurs that
meets once a month and masterminds and
talk about their business and pay a lot
of money to be a part of something like
this and every time I'm around people
who are who are having a high degree of
success
I always try to have them pick me apart
so when we when we do there's an
exercise called hot seats where you go
around the table and you basically share
what your biggest
what you think your biggest problem is
and whenever it gets to my turn I just
want people to ask me questions
because
your biggest problem is you don't know
what your biggest problem is
right your biggest problem is you don't
know what your biggest problem is if you
know what your biggest problem was you
can go and solve it
for for entrepreneurs ambitious people
for you've got goals like you you don't
know what the real problem is the
problem you think you have is a problem
you know the problem you think you have
yes very much is a problem but there's a
deeper problem underneath it that you're
missing
that I'm missing so this is where
question everything becomes important my
default has become instead of pretending
like I know everything and I know all my
problems that I don't know anything and
ask me questions and in the process of
asking me questions and learning about
me maybe you come up with some insight
that I've never seen before
everybody has their own way of
processing
given advice you know so I'm around
people here everybody here has a seven
or eight figure a nine figure business
and people who have sold their
businesses
for nine figures crazy
awesome
and so they have their own way of
processing things and asking questions
and breaking somebody down
so instead of me coming in with
the question and having them try to fit
into my box I'd rather fit into theirs
because in trying to understand how they
process things
it'll probably make me stretch and grow
and learn
and I'm probably going to get a better
result because they're going to see
something that I don't see
and so
in the process of questioning everything
when people can break you down and
you're open to it right because we're we
hold on to our identity like no no
that's not going to work for me you know
even boom got a B I am allergic to bees
maybe I should question that I don't
feel like questioning that today though
do not want to get stung by a bee I once
got stung by a bee and uh only time in
my life I've been sung by bee and it I
was on the floor and my my back just
swelled up from the bee sting
um
anyway maybe question everything except
bee stings how about that uh there's
been times when people have given me
advice and it made sense and it really
fit and sometimes when it didn't
and and even if it doesn't make sense
what I'll default in my head the saying
is this is either nothing like the
person didn't read me correctly or it's
the whole thing
think about if you're really opposed to
somebody's advice or feedback for you if
somebody gives you great advice like oh
wow that's really cool I should go and
do that cool they they met you where
you're at and you understand it
but there'll be other times when it it
doesn't feel right
and it could be that it just wasn't a
fit and they're giving you the wrong
advice or
you're so blind and this is what gets me
excited is maybe I'm so blind maybe I
believe my story so much that the thing
that you're talking about is actually
the whole thing like it's all I should
care about because figuring out how to
solve that because I'm so tied to my own
story that I'm not questioning enough
and coming back to the B Spot hopefully
it's gone I'm not questioning enough
and figuring that out becomes the the
whole unlock so a quick story on this I
did a life coaching session with
garyvee's lead coach Beth hendel and at
first I was shocked I didn't know I
didn't know garyvee had a life coach so
I was very excited to talk to her and
just like I've been explaining this
video I went through her process like
like how do you ask questions what do
you want to know about me I don't want
it to be if this is a coaching session
just treat me as a shoot me as a client
treat me as somebody who's going to
coach what do you need to know from my
story and how I act and I'm gonna I'm
gonna be as open as honest as possible
and what it led to was
a lot of the stuff she was saying
um was great but my single biggest
insight and takeaway was this and I'm
practicing this every single day now
the one takeaway that has honestly
changed my life
historically I've been the person who
believes in the plan
so what's my plan to get to the next
step like I want to go here what's my
plan what's my plan what's my plan so I
have the belief in the plan and I wake
up every day and I just do the plan
because I believe in the plan
I'll have some days where I don't
believe in a plan anymore like will this
plan help get me anywhere is this plan
still working like it's not working
anymore and that leads to some anxiety
for me because I believe in the plan and
when the plan doesn't work what happens
and so what I'll end up doing is making
a new plan
so I have a plan I believe in a plan
until I don't believe in it anymore
causes anxiety come up with a new plan
following so when creating a new plan
then I have certainty in the plan again
and I'm fine and I'm rock and rolling
but there are some days
there are some days when I can't come up
with a new plan the plan I have I don't
believe it anymore and I'm racking my
brain to come up with a new plan and I
can't come up with a new plan
if I'm the kind of person who believes
in the plane and then I can't come up
with a new plan that's a really uh
stress-inducing anxiety-filled place to
be and it doesn't happen that often
but when it does and I can't come up
with a new plan especially in the moment
while what I would end up telling myself
is great things happen to me you know
what you know what happened great things
happen to you
and I would use it as a self-soothing
mechanism as a coping mechanism
because I didn't want to just stay
locked because locked in that stress and
and it would be downward spiral like if
I believe in the plan and the plan is
not working and I can't come with a new
plan then I don't know what to do with
my life and that would create a downward
spiral I've never gone anywhere close to
depression or suicide but that would
lead to some dark that could lead to
some dark places
and so the way that I come out of it is
just say great things will happen to me
great things happen to me they already
they always happen to me great things
happen to me and I'll figure this out
and that gives me the Comfort to
move forward into the uncertainty and
then something will come that I will
solve it and what she said was garyvee's
life coach was
what you say to yourself
when you need that
self-soothing of great things happen to
you
needs to be your default state
so instead of believing in the plan as
your default State and only going to
great things happen to you when you are
at the lowest of your low
flip it to the point where great things
happen to you is the default
because that's where you're actually
your best self and I really felt that I
don't know how to do it
but even in questioning how do I do it
I just have to believe the great things
happen to me so a big part of my routine
now is is I don't know how many times
I'll I'll say that to myself feel that
great things happen to me I'm going to
put it as my new cell phone background
it's a it's a constant reminder even
making this video is another
reinforcement of it when people ask me
what my goals are there's been these
exercises we've been doing in genius
Network here and uh I just I just keep
reminding myself I don't know I don't
have a 10 year goal great things happen
to me
it's a constant reminder and I
I would I used to live it before this
awareness
I don't know like how many times would I
feel really down and low in
anxiety-filled that I couldn't come with
a new plan
maybe half of one percent of the time
like really small amounts and now I'm
probably living in great things happen
to me maybe
five percent of the time ten percent of
the time which is a huge jump from half
of one percent but it's still not my
default mode yet I'm still believing a
planned guy that's my ongoing challenge
to myself that's how I'm questioning
it's the willingness to question what
you're doing because what you're doing
right now has gotten you to where you're
at and if you're if you're happy with
where you're at cool but if you want
more you want to create more you want to
serve more you want to bring more you
want to help more you want more
you want to change and you have to
change and the change starts with not
just questioning everything out there
question everything in here
questioning what you believe to be true
question who you think you are
questioning for sure what you think
you're capable of
because when you can get to the root of
that amazing things can happen
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to manifest success into your life
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there that's where
manifesting comes in manifesting is
preparing your mind body and spirit to
help you take the actions to get those
things that's right